so this whole new album is about your
divorce and your anger around the
divorce not just therefore well it seems
like I mean you have every right to be
super angry because there I just meant
there's also sexy like favorite kind of
high it's it's more of like a when you
first meet someone and you kind of want
to
take their clothes off with your teeth
kind of moment like like it's it's more
of that Vibe but for the most part
you're right in the sense of like it is
a me healing with a lot of like which
anger really the base is hurt so just a
lot of hurt well yeah I mean you had a
lot of trauma in your life and I'm I'm
imagining that you would be angry after
a divorce yeah no it sucks and I'm angry
not just for me but for him and our kids
and it's just it's just hard but you
know what you you get to a point and
everybody if you've been married or not
there's just situations in life you get
to a point with certain relationships to
where there's no try left it's like you
go [__] it I just want out I'm out of
try like I'm exhausted from trying this
should not be this difficult I feel a
lot of your pain and anger come out in
the song Mine this is the song
[Applause]
[Music]
compartmentalization
you wrote the lyrics to this right yes
and the music and the melody yeah wow
beautiful song but thank you
[Music]
you know it's just people kept
it was one of those things like how do
you feel and it's like this is how I
feel I feel like when you're in pain
and it's like so deep you're like it's
you can't describe what it is you know
so you're like I just want you to feel
for a moment what's happening to me and
hey for a moment I'll stop and feel
what's happening with you like but it's
like that's that's where the the song
came from and a lot of
compartmentalization with that line from
the movie Eternal Sunshine the Spotless
Mind but yeah is it is it bittersweet
because you want to come up with a great
song
and and clearly you did but is it
Bittersweet in a way like you go oh wow
I just created great art out of this but
look my [__] life I've gotta you know
my life's got to be torn up in order for
this song to be born
uh no yeah no there's no part of me that
I mean I'd rather not have this album so
there's right Zero part of me I'm not
that kind of artist like and I love
writing like obviously I've written a
lot of my songs but um I also don't mind
being the vessel obviously I cover music
all the time like so I don't mind being
the vessel for somebody else's message I
feel like as long as I relate to the
song I can be a great vessel for it so
I'd no I'd rather other people write it
and then me not be um living a dumpster
fire I would also think for you because
of your unique situation
a husband would have to be or someone
who loves you would have to be your
biggest cheerleader too
because you didn't have that with a man
yeah but I will say this I I will I will
give my ex Credit in this like he
probably I mean he's there was no point
where I didn't think he believed in me
as an artist or believed what I was
capable of
um he was very much a tailor he's the
reason why
um you know he really like pushed me to
do the TV show because I was like why
would I do that
um so I I think that he was a great
cheerleader for me but okay but it's
it's not so much that
um it's just that I think
well it's really hard to say when you
can't say
I'll tell you what you're trying to say
you had a dull your light
yes and that's what Lighthouse is about
that was the song and I was on a flight
home from dropping off my kids and
with him and
I just still had been on the fence and
it just but it just had gotten so brutal
that I was like I don't think there's
any light left like I don't think
like there's any hope left and I am a
person that always sees hope and
potential so like that was a really
really hard day but I think that I'm
smart enough to listen
you know and wise enough with age like
to know that like one relationship
doesn't Define them all
um
even if you know
they're good parts of you know um you
know that relationship too but I I think
for me
I would love to fall in love I'm not
against love at all I'm not really into
marriage
um I think that that hits people the
wrong way but I think marriage is
beautiful and I think that's awesome for
some people and I think that's
incredible but I don't think it suits me
at this point in my life
foreign